[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Kathy hokel
is Westchester ready to save our state
I love this fired up crowd how about
those Pataki 1994 signs let me see those
you know our state was at a Crossroads
it was 28 years ago
and it was an important moment for us to
do everything in our power then
and think of how different things would
have gone
if not for the people of New York
stepping up taking control of their
future and their Destiny it
it might have been the last time that we
were just eight days away
from an opportunity to to take control
of your family's future to change the
trajectory of the state to restore
balance and Common Sense back to Albany
to make sure that those those attacks on
your wallets and your safety and your
your freedom and the quality of our kids
education can be reversed it's up to all
of us
to do everything in our power with just
eight days to go taking nothing at all
for granted
these opportunities don't come by often
and sometimes when you you feel like
maybe hopefully you're two or three
years away from that next chance
and then it comes and goes
and it's still just more of the same
under one party rule up in Albany the
lack of balance has resulted in laws
like cashless Bell getting passed and
other pro-criminal laws
there's a tolerance for district
attorneys who refuse to enforce the law
there are attacks on our men and women
in law enforcement
taxes go up spending goes up
they look at your freedom
as if a transaction with the government
with your freedom
is one where the government is taking it
away but the only way that we should be
engaging in a transaction with
government with your freedom is for you
to be getting more of your freedoms back
not the other way around
[Applause]
this is about when you get money back
from the government government
understands it was your money in the
first place
don't demand don't expect to thank you
right now we have a governor who has
referred to all of us as her apostles
I promise you that at no point will I
ever refer to you as my apostle
we have a governor right now who refuse
she refers to herself as the mother of
New York's 62 counties
I promise you
that at no point will you ever hear me
refer to myself as the father of New
York 62 counties
it won't happen
this is about all of you taking control
of your government again you don't want
to be ruled by an emperor Governor Kathy
Holcomb wasn't even elected governor
she was elected lieutenant governor and
she's filling the remainder of someone
else's term
it's important to stay humble and
grounded
I'm running to be the governor for all
New Yorkers Republicans and Democrats
and independents
[Applause]
and this isn't about Republicans versus
Democrats this is about all of us
together Republicans Democrats and
independents uniting as New Yorkers to
save our state
but Kathy hokel doesn't feel that way
in August she declared that I was no
longer a New Yorker
she demanded that I get on a bus and
move to Florida
now the next day I kind of took her
advice a little bit I I got in my car
and I went to Florida New York
I was endorsed by the mayor of Florida
and New York and we campaigned together
but I'm not going anywhere and you're
not going anywhere we are staying and
fighting for our state
and listen
I'm not here to say that Kathy hokel's
not a New Yorker
and I'm not here to demand that she get
on a bus and leave the state
I'm just saying that she needs to get
out of the governor's mansion
and you all have that power
to reverse those ataxi New York leads
the entire country and out migration
and we want to be able to proudly say
that we live in the greatest state in
the greatest country in the history of
the world and for us to be able to do
that
we have to have a good response with our
family and friends in other states see
right now they say well you claim that
you live in the greatest state but
your state leads the entire country in
population loss
it's true
we have to reverse that
so I did an interview on a Sunday
morning Futures with Maria bar Romo a
couple Sundays ago
and she asked me
what I was going to try to accomplish in
the first 100 days
and my thought as soon as I heard that
question is honestly this is about what
we can accomplish in the first 100
minutes
we can't waste any time
and I made a pledge I've told people
that listen in New York state we do not
have recall elections and we have a
problem when District Attorneys release
violent criminals to roam free we have a
problem with soaring crime we want DA's
to understand that that stands for
district attorney not defense attorney
so the first thing that I'm going to do
the first day that I'm in office is
turning the Manhattan district attorney
Alvin Bragg to tell him that he's being
fired
[Applause]
and by the way there is a crime
emergency going on right now in this
state even though Kathy hulkel says
there's nothing to see here look away
she says that she says that we're we're
data deniers well go ask the family of
Connie Torrey who lost
their 93 year old
grandmother
because of someone who is released due
to Castle spell
there are many people
across this state who will share stories
like two Mexican cartel drug smugglers
busted with 1.2 million dollars worth of
Crystal Method and instantly released on
Castle spell
we had a guy at the McDonald's on
Delancey Street in lower Manhattan who
pulled an ax out of his backpack and
started swinging it wildly at tables
and at walls and at customers
and instantly released back out on the
street on Castle spell
not too far from here in the Bronx Jesus
Cortez was knocked into a coma
the person who did that
was out on parole a convicted sex
offender he put on a glove and this
wasn't like any regular glove this glove
was a weapon
and the NYPD looked at the video and
they charged attempted murder but then
the Bronx district attorney reduced it
to misdemeanor assault and harassment
and then while Jesus Cortez was laying
in a bed in a coma
the person who punched him deliberately
with clear intents was able to walk free
under New York's Castle spell law
a woman in a Howard Beach subway station
ends up getting attacked by a guy who
had once killed his own grandparents
violates his parole this past August
but what was reported was that the
reason why
that person wasn't violated detained by
his parole officer was because of the
less is more act we hear stories about
because of raise the age that you have
teenagers being used to commit crime
After Crime After Crime After Crime we
hear in our prisons that because of the
halt act which went to effect on April
1st
that attacks on a correctional officers
and other prison staff and even inmates
have gone up
well we should have zero tolerance for
this crime Kathy hokel says that she
doesn't understand why it is so
important to me that we lock up
criminals
and when she says that she doesn't
understand why this is so important to
me she is saying that she does not
understand why this is so important to
all of you
on day one I will declare a crime
emergency here in the state of New York
[Applause]
and I will suspend New York's castless
bail law and these other pro-criminal
laws to force the state legislature to
come to the table to fix this
and I also believe by the way that there
that every last covid vaccine mandate
that we can get rid of here in the state
of New York should be gone
[Applause]
there should be no covid vaccine mandate
to work
no covid vaccine mandate to be able to
go to your higher ed class
and I would absolutely veto in a
heartbeat any legislation that wants to
mandate the coveted vaccine for our kids
[Applause]
I'll tell you what else we'll do on day
one
parent has a fundamental right to
control the upbringing of their child
and they do not relinquish that right to
the government by sending their kids off
to school
that will be the policy of New York
State
we have a lot to accomplish
and we are right here in a congressional
district
we are in a congressional district where
you have an opportunity to help flip
balance of power here in the House of
Representatives by electing Mike LawLers
your next congressman
[Applause]
and you could tell your friends in New
York 18. to vote for Army veteran Colin
Schmidt
tell your friends in New York 19 to
elect another special guest we have here
today Marcus Molinaro
and now
all of all these great candidates
running for State Legislative seats in
Congress all over the map we have an
opportunity to restore balance now I
have a question for this crowd
and uh and listen list pay close
attention because I don't want to
accidentally trick you
how does this crowd think
about changing Senate Majority Leader
Chuck Schumer
[Applause]
how would you all
how would you all like to turn Senate
Majority Leader Chuck Schumer into
Senate minority leader Chuck Schumer
oh no no
no
Hey Joe come up here for a second
how many of you are ready to turn Senate
Majority Leader Chuck Schumer
into former Senator Chuck Schumer
an electro opinion as the next Senator
here in the great state of New York Jose
quickcolo
so some of you may have seen a debate
last night
I've heard a rumor there uh there's a
bolo out there uh elder abuse a warrant
has been issued
but I'll say this we heard from the
Senate majority Leader's mouth he wants
to pack the Supreme Court he wants to
mandate the jab for your children he
wants to make sure that he can lower
your electric bill 30 years from now
he's been there for 42 years we
certainly cannot afford six more and so
that's why we're going to send Lee
zeldin to the governor's mansion
[Applause]
that's why we are here to ensure that
after 24 years in the Senate 42 years in
Congress we can send this geriatric
dinosaur to the retirement home
apothesis once and for all
[Applause]
so as I say always we've got what I've
now called a three for one sale we get
you fire Kathy hokel we get to dismiss
Tish and we get to retire Charles Ellis
Schumer but it's a one-day sale so you
guys gotta be there and be there quick
God bless you all make sure you spread
the word Charles Schumer has seen his
last days in DC and leave zeldin is
gonna Shock the World on November 8th
[Applause]
Joe opinion everybody
all right so this is this is our
opportunity here in eight days doing our
little part in this corner of America to
make sure that when we are all tuning
into C-SPAN at the beginning of January
that we will get to watch the gavel
permanently coming out of the hands of
former speaker Nancy Pelosi
we want to restore balance to Washington
and we have a great opportunity to
restore balance here in New York
and there was a big race that took place
last year
all eyes were on Virginia
they said that the race could not be won
and a man of principles stepped up
he was fighting for parents
he was fighting for taxpayers
he was fighting for freedom
his state was at a Crossroads
and he was not going to let
and his constituents his voters were not
going to let that opportunity pass them
by
he did what many said was impossible
we are going to do
what many said was impossible
just like 28 years ago
when New York stepped up to elect a
great governor and George Pataki
here we are at our moment November 8th
of 2022.
where we will do everything in our power
taking nothing for granted telling
friends and family and neighbors and
strangers and co-workers being active on
social media and emails and texts and
Word of Mouth early voting is now open
we have to get our vote out no one can
stay at home
and on Election night Tuesday November
8th you all will be able to listen to
you all will be able to watch a
concession speech of soon to be former
Governor Kathy hokel
[Applause]
and a man who has inspired so many
parents here in Westchester County
a man who has inspired so many people
fighting for freedom and good government
sane government
he's been a great leader who's kept to
his word
and we're honored to have him today as a
very special guest
ladies and gentlemen give a big New York
welcome to the governor of Virginia
Glenn yonkin
[Applause]
[Music]
laughs
foreign
[Music]
I'm gonna go to the place
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right New York
[Applause]
how about your next governor
[Applause]
can you feel what's happening
you can feel it
the momentum is building like they can't
believe you can see them all of a sudden
go from cocky to scared it happens just
like that
because it's just like a race it's like
a NASCAR race you know you got Kathy
Hogle kind of kind of bumping along the
final term and here comes Lee Zelda on
the outside
[Applause]
and you know what happens is you've got
to scrape a little paint there on the
outside and that's all they know to do
Lee's got no problem with that because
he is racing to the Finish to beat York
next governor
[Applause]
you know friends when I was flying up
here today I was thinking about all the
great things that make New York great
and it is a long list
but I have to tell you the stuff that
really really goes to the top is the
fact that New York's where you go to
make it
it's where you go to make it whether
whether whether it's the Bronx
or whether it's whether it's upstate New
York
bye folks if you make it in New York you
can make it anywhere
that
is the spirit of New York by the way
that's the spirit of America that's the
spirit of Virginia that's what holds us
all together is it's the land of
opportunity and right here's the heart
of it in New York
but you see what's happening
what's happening is the liberal
Progressive Democrats are trying to
squash that Spirit they're trying to
take it away from us that's what they're
trying to do
folks it can happen like that
it can happen like that I watched it in
my beloved Virginia
it happened like that here going to walk
with me go on a walk with me just a few
years ago Virginia was locked tight
during the pandemic businesses were shot
schools were shut people stayed were
told to stay in their house that sound
familiar in New York
by the way small businesses were closed
in in Bristol Virginia all the
businesses were shot right across the
street in Bristol Tennessee they were
open having a party
people were told to stay home from work
and paid to be there by the government
sound familiar New York
by the way we had leaders who stood up
for criminals not victims sound familiar
New York
we had a parole board that was criminal
friendly not victim friendly and let
them all out they actually wanted to
wave the magic wand and set them free
sound familiar New York
we had more people moving away from
Virginia than moving to Virginia from
the other 49 states sound familiar New
York
and parents in Virginia were told
that their kids watching a 14-inch
screen was a quality education and that
those parents had no right to have a say
in their kids life sound familiar in New
York
friends
the spirit of New York that's
that's like that
and that's what the Progressive
Democrats want to do
that's what they want to do listen you
know these answers
I mean do you want
a law enforcement philosophy that is
Criminal first and victim last
Kathy hokel does
do you want law enforcement that's
demeaned and demoralized no Kathy Hogle
does do you want your already high taxes
to go even higher
Kathy hokel does do you want politics to
be taught in your classroom so that your
children are taught what to think versus
how to think
Kathy hokel does
you know it you know it and here we
stand today at a moment just like I was
in last year
where five months ago six months ago all
those smart pundits said well
a Democrat can't win in New York that's
exactly what the Republican can't win in
New York that's exactly what the
Democrat can't win in New York you know
that
said a republican can't win in New York
and that's exactly what they said in
Virginia last year they said no
Republican can win for governor in
Virginia the suburbs are too blue the
media is too strong they forgot to do
one thing ask the voters that's what
they forgot to do
Virginia
where life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness was breathed into our country
too blue for Republican governor no way
we won the Hispanic vote we won the
Asian vote we won more of the black vote
anybody's ever seen we won Terror we run
cities that Republicans had never won
why because we came together in a way
and stood up and said no and it's New
York's turn to say no
it's your turn
I'm here to pass the Baton to lead
zeldin for him to finish and become your
next governor
do you know how exciting it's going to
be
you all on November the 8th they're
going to watch something happen that's
going to send a Shockwave around the
world a shock wave when all of a sudden
you all recognize that your 58th
Governor is gonna be Lee zeldin that's
what's gonna happen
but it's up to all of you and it's a
really clear choice I mean you got Kathy
Hogle on this side on this side remember
I'm right not left
on this side you got Lee Zelda let me
just you guys know him but let me just
tell you about him he's homegrown right
here in New York
he knows how to fight for his country by
the way he jumped out of too many
perfectly good airplanes
he came back to New York and and he
served New Yorkers in the state senate
he served them in Washington he
understands that government is for the
people he understands this
this is a clear choice
and on the other side
we've got Kathy Holcomb we have got Joe
Biden
I know
France
friends it is our time to recognize
that they are agents of Chaos
everything they touch they make worse
we have we have lawlessness what do they
do they ask a very basic question
why is it so important to you
well I'm going to tell you Lee zeldin
understands why it's so important he
understands that you you actually have
to back the blue
he understands that you have to have
DA's who will prosecute
he understands that it is time to
eliminate forever cashless bail
folks it's real simple
you want to take care of crime you got
to put more badges on the street it's
that simple
and you gotta back them they gotta know
that their governor has their back and
Lee zeldin is gonna have their back
because they have ours friends you you
got you got you got Kathy and Joe who
see runaway inflation and the first
thing they do is pass bills to spend
more and throw a garden party we got cat
we got Kathy and Joe who sit there and
look at our schools failing and what do
they want to do push parents out and
lock them out of their kid's life well
I'm gonna tell you what Lee zeldon
understands that parents matter that's
what he understands
at the end of the day this is about
Liberty and freedom we know that it's
about Liberty and freedom and I have to
say that in Virginia we know a little
bit about Liberty and freedom
listen the most Immortal words ever
written in this hemisphere were written
by a Virginia and you know when we hold
these truths to be self-evident that all
men are created equal and that they are
endowed by their creator with certain
inalienable rights and among them are
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness
friends
these are not rights that are granted to
us by a king these are not rights that
are handed down to us by Elites in
Albany or in Richmond or in Washington
these are rights that are granted to us
by a God almighty
and they are ours to defend
so come on New York it's time to lock
arms and defend them we have got to get
Lee zeldon elected governor
[Applause]
and you all know how to do this
the work starts right now you have eight
days eight days early voting is
happening you gotta get out to the polls
friends listen here's rule number one
each one of you has got to be
responsible for ten friends ten friends
that aren't here
and by the way 10 friends are gonna vote
the right way
your job's to write down their name call
them and say hey have you voted yet and
if they say no say We'll vote tomorrow
and then call them the next day and if
they say have you voted yet and they say
no go pick them up at your car and take
them to vote you got to get the vote out
you get the vote out you win folks there
should be a sign in every yard a hat on
every head a bumper sticker on every car
Shucks you might as well all put on red
vests
[Applause]
you can do this
we proved it last year you lock arms and
you get this done because elections have
consequences
and the consequences for not electing
Lee zeldin will be Dyer in New York and
you know it folks the winning team is
the winning team
and we are on the team that believes in
safe communities
we are on the team that believes in
strong families we are on the team that
believes in low taxes small business
American-made products
we are on the team that believes in
peace through strength not weakness
through weakness we are on the team that
believes in Liberty and freedom and the
unbridled opportunities that come for
everyone when we lift them up we are on
the team that believes
that parents matter
[Music]
this is your moment it's a movement
folks this is not just an election it is
a movement it's a movement that's been
brought together by the spirit of New
York it's a movement that's been brought
together by your shared belief in these
common principles this common commitment
to grit this common commitment to
deliver this common commitment to God
and Country this common commitment to
elect zalese Alden the 58th governor of
New York let's get this done God bless
you God bless New York
[Music]
don't wanna smile
[Music]
different way
don't stop thinking